have you seen Wonka yet wonder what went
into making this amazing re-imagining of
a classic character well we've got all
the behind the scenes secrets from the
chocolateers who worked on the set to
the part of filming that Hugh Grant
called a quote torture chamber Wonka
probably isn't the first time you've
heard of Willie Wonka Ro doll's famous
novel Charlie in the Chocolate Factory
was published in
1964 the 1971 film adaptation Willie
Wonka and the Chocolate Factory starred
Jean Wilder as Willie Wonka and Tim
Burton's 2005 remake star Johnny Depp so
why make another remake well there's a
lot about this film that is different
from the others this Willy Wonka is the
story of the beginning of Willy Wonka
and the ambitious young chocolate here
who hasn't made it yet who's full of
ambition full of joy full of a hat full
of dreams but isn't quite where he wants
to be at unlike the previous two Wily
Wonka films Wonka is a prequel this
isn't the uh the Gene Wilder we all know
in love that's sort of crazed and
demented and looking to give his Factory
away this is a story of a young Willie
who's ambitious and sensitive and joyous
director Paul King developed the story
and the film's unique Vision I love the
backstory how Paul explained who he is
and why he is it's just so clever
because we never really kind of knew
that before and now there is a whole
there's a whole kind of explanation the
desire to know this famous character's
backstory inspired the idea for the
we were interested in telling the story
of Willie woner before he was famous and
before he had the chocolate Factor when
he was a sort of young man first going
out into the world and and hoping to
find a a place which rewarded talent and
hard work startled and disappointed to
discover the world is a tougher place
than he first imagine so in many ways
Wonka isn't a remake of Willie Wonka
instead it aims to add on to the story
we know and love we wanted to make a
film that would stand as a companion
piece to the book and the 1971 movie and
and and not sort of have anything that
would uh disrupt your enjoyment of those
pieces while this prequel aims to add on
to the famous 1971 film that doesn't
mean that filling Gan Wilder shoes in
this iconic role was an easy task but
shalam was open to the challenge his
performance is so Titanic it's so
perfect so what would Wilder think of
this prequel I think he was very
protective over the character rightfully
because he did it so perfectly I would
be afraid to ask him
honestly to his film either way plenty
of folks believe that shalam was the
right man for the job he is amazing here
we are on Day 70 and every day he brings
something new to the table and shalom's
unique similarities to the iconic
character make his portrayal even
stronger he like Willie is mischievous
with a twinkle in his eye he is Soulful
and beautiful bringing him to life in
the most Vivid and magical way I canot
not think of anyone else today who could
play Willie and bring him to life the
way that Timmy has and shalam wasn't the
only actor portraying an iconic
character Hugh Grant had the difficult
task of playing an Oompa Loompa I did
watch the earlier films and then I
thought how do we make this different
but I I definitely thought the key was
to to keep the sort of kagin element of
of
the I you know this is my speciality in
shalom's opinion though the script is
what made their great interpretations
possible if the script wasn't so good it
would have felt Blasphemous giving
Willie Wonka New Life wasn't the only
part of the film that was a challenge
for Timothy shalam the fact that Wonka
is a musical also provided its fair
share of difficulties there was more
training that went into this than maybe
anything i' ever worked on because
there's an element of song and dance
that you have to spend months uh
prepping obviously for the songs you got
to record them and just how difficult
dance numbers are took the actor by
surprise for the dance numbers I've
talked about it before but I was really
humbled by it's not simply about raw
expression you really got to stay in the
center of frame on some shots some shots
you might be killing it but another
dancer might have messed up you know all
sorts of variables that you wouldn't
really consider an AB talking scene you
know the actors helped to bring the
world to life but the set was an
important element too the W cassette is
awesome it's amazing and it was
practically built very little green
screen and while sham admits that he
didn't bring home any set pieces I did
Jack a jacket though I took one of the
jackets those jackets were just as
important as the set lots of thought
went into the costumes the fundamental
thing about Willie Wonka and his whole
costume is that by the time you meet him
at the beginning of the film he's been
wandering the world in some part some of
these clothes he's owned all of those
clothes and he's been wandering the
world sometimes to hot countries where
he wouldn't be wearing his velvet coat
and then other times to colder places
where he would while Wily's wardrobe was
all about those purple coats the Oompa
looma wardrobe was a bit more harrowing
since it was all motion capture they put
me in a sort of torture chamber and
covered me in wires and I I I did my
best in addition to new versions of
beloved characters Wonka has new
characters as well kala Lane plays
noodle I'd say she's like a tough
character she doesn't want to open up
her heart to anybody but when she meets
Willie she kind of cracks and she's like
oh well somebody loves me somebody likes
me and so she she kind of cracks and
she's just like no maybe I can bring my
love out to other people too comedian
Keegan Michael key is also a major
member of the cast I played the chief of
police a man who is beholden to the
chocolate cartel he is one of the
biggest obstacles to Willy Wonka
starting his Enterprise and clearly
these new characters will become
Classics too I was very upset last night
to see the film The First Time and to
realize how good you were being and how
many laughs you were getting and all
that I heard you swearing loudly every
time Keegan got a good response I didn't
like it one important piece of all
iterations of wily Wonka's story
chocolate of course consequently real
chocolateers worked on the film to be
able to design and make the chocolates
for such a story and a film this is the
most creative quirky most extraordinary
choler in the entire world for me to
have this job of creating these
chocolates is just a dream come true and
such an honor and yes this means there
was tons of chocolate on set Paul King
joked that he gained 50 lbs working on
the project and yes if you were
wondering the actors did actually wade
into a giant vat of hot chocolate no
wonder the actors had so much fun
working on this movie what was your
favorite part of Wonka did Timothy
shalamay fill the famous purple shoes
well let us know in the comments and for
more videos like this one like And
subscribe to the thanks